you're always got a percentage
possibility even in the least risky of
something going badly and yet often when
something goes badly we take it as
a violation of the laws of nature but if
you go by probability if something's got
a 90 probability of success 10 of the
time it's going to go very badly and we
shouldn't be surprised we shouldn't be
upset that should be in our mindset but
we don't do that very well you know if
it's 70
chance of good weather we don't carry an
umbrella because
and yet if i said chris it's 30 chance
of rain today you'd probably go back in
the house get your umbrella in a
raincoat
general stanley mcchrystal welcome to
the show
well chris thanks for having me please
call me stan i was gonna say it's kind
of difficult to work out what to say
calling a four-star general stan
feels
oddly informal
i've been called a lot worse chris so
stan would be great what what does
what's the four stars mean what does
that mean in a general for the
non-initiates amongst us
sure there are four levels of being a
general a brigadier general is one star
a major generalist two stars a
lieutenant general is three stars and
then a plain general is four stars and
then
only occasionally in american history we
created a general of the army which is
five stars but the last one was during
the second world war all right okay so
only in times of real necessity does
anyone get above that
exactly right so that's a lot of
pressure on your shoulders then
given the fact that you spent so much
time in afghanistan and the last few
weeks and months we've seen some pretty
crazy imagery coming out of that what's
it been like watching that from the
sidelines having invested so much time
in it
well it's difficult not just because of
the investment but more because i got
very
close to the afghan people
i believed very much that they had the
ability and the um
all the things necessary to pull their
society forward and the fact that it it
has now been at least put on hold is
disappointing
um yeah it's uh i heard you speaking
a while ago i think it was at a live
event where the trump midterm elections
were going on and someone brought up
afghanistan in the withdrawal and you
identified the sort of prisoner's
dilemma
that's going to happen that if
any president decides to do it and then
you have taliban and isis retaking
control it's sort of this this odd game
of chicken that they're playing and it
seems like that kind of played out
i think it did and to review that
generally every president had the
opportunity to do more
do less or do the same and there was
political risk to do more domestic
resistance
and there was
real risk in doing less i.e pulling out
because if al qaeda or isis establishes
a safe haven again then any decision
maker connected to that will be
criticized which meant that in the
middle
was typically the safe it didn't make it
the wrong option but it made it the safe
one so i've got a lot of sympathy for
decision makers you know we all sit on
the sidelines and we criticize this
decision maker for doing that and this
decision maker for doing something else
but unless you've been down on the field
making those decisions i think we've got
to be a little bit more forgiving
that's the word of the day risk that you
just mentioned there why are you so
interested in it
well
because i don't think we think about
risk well i went through a lifetime
dealing with risk
talking about risk sometimes trying to
measure risk and i came away with a
conclusion we don't do it very well
and that the sort of frustrating reality
is that the greatest risk to us
is us
and let me explain
most of us think about risk in terms of
probability and consequences
if i if i climb up on the roof
what's the likelihood i'll fall off and
if i do fall off what's the likelihood
i'll get badly hurt and if both are low
you don't worry too much if both are up
you do worry
but i'd ask you to think about risk
instead like a mathematical equation
threat times vulnerability equals risk
and i'm not good at math but stay with
me
if the threats out there
are zero if you can make all the threats
to you go away
then you've got no risk because anything
times zero is zero
but we can't do that at least i've never
been in that situation
and we really can't even control the
threats we don't predict them very well
we're not exactly sure what form they'll
take
but we do control our vulnerabilities we
have greater control and so that's the
place we probably can't drive them to
zero but what we can do is make
ourselves and our organizations much
stronger and more resilient and so while
people spend a lot of time
obsessing about what's around the corner
or over the hill or coming from outer
space
what we should be doing is standing in
the mirror individually and getting our
organizations together
how do we become the most resilient
teams possible so no matter what comes
up we're going to be able to deal with
it what do you mean by vulnerability and
resilience in this context
well vulnerabilities are those
weaknesses in an organization there
might be blind spots they might be
things you don't do well your inability
inside the organization to communicate
or poor leadership or lack of diverse
perspectives any number of those things
and when you have those weaknesses they
become
vulnerabilities
and so they add to risk so for example
if i've got a very cohesive team that
communicates well it's superbly led we
overcome inertia make decisions all of
the good things we want
when suddenly the unexpected threat
comes up we're not knocked off our feet
we we can step back we can assess it we
can deal with it and we can move forward
however if we're not
if we're sort of flawed
every time a wave goes over the deck it
causes the boat to get more unstable and
if you've got holes in the bottom of the
boat you get big problems
i guess that through your career back
back history risk was
turned up to 11 that it's grave it's
mortal right it's as high of a
externality as you can get
it was
but the reality is it didn't mean we
dealt with it better
because it's hard to deal with
its first hard to get your mind around
it's hard to communicate it i remember i
spent most of my career in special
operations
and we would do an operation that was
high risk
and we would be
going to communicate to political
leaders who had to approve the operation
and they'd say
how risky is it and you'd say high risk
and you could look them in the eye and
that didn't have any meaning to them
they'd seen the movie black hawk down in
zero dark 30 so they knew what movies
high risk but they had a level of
confidence that even though it was high
risk that was our business so really
it wasn't very risky
and we had one operation when i had left
special operations i came back to the
pentagon
and this operation had gone across the
border into pakistan and ended up into a
firefight and this guy called me just
distraught
and he said ah it's terrible how could
that happen and i said what do you mean
and he goes who screwed it up i said i
was in the briefing what about high risk
did you not understand
you always got a percentage possibility
even in the
the least risky of something going badly
and yet often when something goes badly
we take it as a violation of the laws of
nature
you know
but if you go by probability if
something's got a 90 probability of
success 10 of the time it's going to go
very badly
and we shouldn't be surprised we
shouldn't be upset that should be in our
mindset but we don't do that very well
you know if it's 70
chance of
good weather we don't carry an umbrella
because
and yet if i said chris it's 30 chance
of rain today you'd probably go back in
the house get your umbrella in a
raincoat yeah so framing's important
then yeah it's really important
what's the goal with risk analysis is it
to never fail is it to be able to see
the world more accurately
it's a great question
uh it depends on
who's describing that to you sometimes
people say the idea of risk analysis is
to avoid risk completely
or to mitigate risk i.e
plug up every potential way that that
risk could come home and i don't think
that's what it is i think risk analysis
is to give you a sense of the level of
risk and the probability of success or
failure it's to give you a realistic
basis for judging on whether you want to
do something almost everything in life
has a level of risk
but if you think about it some things
aren't worth accepting much risk for
because the payoff is fairly low but if
the payoff is higher the key thing is
understanding what the real level of
risk is we go back to things like the
financial crisis of 2008 one of the
challenges was they had lost
clarity on what the actual risks were
they could no longer assess them
effectively and so risk analysis had
failed
yeah the payoffs were incredibly high
but the risks were somehow even higher
exactly yeah it's i like the way that
you've split off risk into threats and
vulnerabilities because i think one of
the easy criticisms around risk analysis
would be to say that you're spending a
lot of time trying to control things
that you can't control all of these
externalities over which you don't have
any bearing on how they're going to
behave
but what we're talking about here is
look that's there background risk is
going to exist what can you do to
prepare yourself moving forward
if you take it down to a very individual
level if you're going to walk down a
street
and someone says it's a pretty risky
place you make that decision to walk
down crime or whatever
and if you do nothing to prepare
yourself if any of that risk comes
to fruition you're probably in trouble
but if you make yourself physically more
capable maybe wear body arm or
whatever's appropriate in the moment
you then control that and so the risks
which will inevitably
with a certain level of probability
arise you can deal with them and that's
the key that's where we have agency
we can control that we have
responsibility and i would argue that
our societies and many of our
organizations
focus on the outside and we take a pass
on doing those things which we should
responsibly do to be more prepared
internally who was major general john
sedgwick
john cedric was a hero he went to the
united states military academy where i
ended up going he graduated in 1837 and
they had this distinguished career
before the american civil war he'd been
in a series of wars the mexican war wars
on the the frontiers and then during the
civil war he becomes a distinguished
commander
unfortunately he is often remembered
for two things there's a statue of him
at west point and if you are failing a
course
legend says that if you sneak out at
night wearing your full dress uniform
carrying your weapon and you go to the
statue and you spin the rowells that's
at the uh
the spikes on the back of the spurs they
were around if you spin those you'll
pass the course now you could study but
this is easier just go out at midnight
and solve your problem
um
but he's also
well known for a quote that is
attributed to him
he was at the battle of spotsylvania and
he gets up to a position where he can
see the fighting going on and he's
observing this and some of his leaders
come to and say general you got to get
back
it is too dangerous up here and he
points at the confederates and he says
they couldn't hit an elephant at this
distance and in a moment
he gets hit and he's dead
and so
wonderful guy and unfortunately he is
almost with a tongue-in-cheek memory
from how he died
what do you think looking back on your
time in the armed forces and and risk
what were some of the things that they
got right about the way that they judged
risk
yeah i think when organizations
were designed to deal with risk they
were most effective when they die
designed themselves to be very adaptable
in the early years of special operations
we started doing things related to
counter-terrorist operations
and you've probably seen in movies where
commanders will go in a building and the
first guy will go left the next guy will
go right and everybody goes as though
it's a ballet that's been rehearsed a
hundred times they throw things up in
the air next guy catches it and they
move around like that yeah that's how it
goes right yeah
i i assume it does in movies anyway
i never saw an app like that
and so when i first got into special
operations that stuff was kind of
popular and you'd sometimes see
demonstrations put on by commandos for
outsiders and people would just be in
awe
we learned that you don't actually train
that way what you have to do is train so
that always goes badly you have the
first guy go in and you designate him as
a casualty to fall down and then you
make the organization deal with that
unexpected
reality and so the more you make them
able to adapt to whatever happens the
lights go on lights go off flood you
know any number of things they become
problem solvers in a constantly changing
set of unknowns
then they become
resilient they become confident they
become used to adapting they aren't
thrown off their game by that and so the
best organizations
build that into their dna it doesn't
come naturally
because doctrine and procedures are
designed to get everything lined up if
you're a senior officer and you come up
with a plan you put together a battle
plan you brief it to everybody and you
have some ridiculous belief that that's
what's actually going to happen
it never does as they say no plan
survives contact with the enemy
once you're in contact the plan goes to
hell
but the planning can give you the
confidence and the ability to know what
your options are to know how to what we
call you know react to the unexpected
what about communication then it seems
like that's the first step to get right
if you can't communicate any plan no
matter how
awry things go no one knows what they're
supposed to do
yeah and it goes on various levels if i
say communication you might say well you
and i are communicating now
but there are actually four parts or
four tests to communication the first is
do you have the physical technical
ability to communicate and if you're not
close together it usually involves some
kind of radio or phone or something does
that work
the second is as the communicator
am i willing to communicate if i know 10
things am i willing to communicate those
to you and in many cases we find people
are not for a host of reasons they hold
information close they don't trust you
and so information is flawed simply
because i won't send it
then there's a question of is the
information i'm sending correct and
timely
so is what i'm saying even if it's
unintentional on my part am i sending
you crap
and then the final one is your ability
to understand and digest it your ability
to if i'm speaking one language and you
speak another it may be of no use to you
or if i'm from one background even for
speaking the same language the
terminology and whatnot gives you no
contextual ability so first you've got
to have communication that actually gets
uh from one place to another and is
understood
and then
you've got to communicate
a number of things you've got to
communicate a situation you've got to
communicate what the intent is what are
we trying to do and you've got to have
constant ability to update so people
have a two-way communication so we know
what's happening and we can adapt in
real time
that was of course one of the great
stories from the first world war used to
be that
they would start these big offensive on
offensives on the western front and they
would be connected from the front line
of trenches back to headquarters with
wire because that was there was initial
radio but it wasn't very good so they'd
go back to wire so they would put
together this great plan but as once as
soon as the troops came out of the
trenches
moved forward they were essentially out
of communication
because the wire only went to the fore
trench
then you're trying to do this
carefully timed operation to have
artillery go right in front of them to
coordinate different arms and it would
go to pieces because the communication
capability just wasn't flexible enough
and how many times do we see in
organizations where the left hand
doesn't know what the right hand is
doing for any number of reasons
the technological issue has been removed
largely now you know in most
organizations you've got frictionless
communication that's in in fact if
anything
in the space of a hundred years we've
gone from a scarcity of communication to
a surplus of communication and
yeah i think it's the nuances
a lot more now that people are battling
with
yeah that's true i mean we we haven't
completely solved the technical part but
we've mostly solved it we can
communicate now we've got new problems
we've got too much communication so
you've got too much noise and you can't
focus on the signal and then we've got
the insidious problems of misinformation
and then even worse disinformation
intentional
uh
misrepresentation of facts and so you
corrupt this system with information
that actually you know draws wrong
conclusions it's benefited from the
frictionlessness of the communication
mediums right that's what's permitted
misinformation and disinformation to
propagate so quickly it's the fact that
it is so easy and free and shareable and
limbically hijacked that's what's giving
it its power that's what motivates it
and pushes it forward
yeah that communication the cost of
communications driven almost to zero now
and the other problem is it's so
convenient i tell people
we can communicate faster than we can
think
and i think twitter is a great
representation of that people will hear
something and they will tweet about it
before they've sat back and said now
what do i really think about that what
do i really want to say
and
it's not just twitter it's it's other
things as well if we were only allowed
to communicate a certain amount each day
and we had to stop and think what are
the most important things i want to send
out to friends or to wider elements
we might do better during the civil war
ulysses grant as did most generals
would send their orders out
handwritten and so general grant would
sit down with a pencil and a little
orders book little pages you could tear
out and he would hand write instructions
to general officers well when you're
handwriting particularly in the dark and
you're tired you tend to be succinct
you tend to get to the point
and if you know that they're tired and
they're probably in the dark and you'll
be reading by candlelight you don't want
to waste a lot of words so you do it
just word processing now allows us to
take a document and keep expanding it
until people don't have time to read it
and so if we had to hand write stuff
we would probably get to the point far
faster than we do
wasn't it napoleon who used to take two
weeks
to respond to orders have i got this
right i'm pretty sure that he used to
leave
messages on his desk for two weeks and
his justification for that was that
usually within the space of two weeks
things had either sorted themselves out
or it was so important that someone had
sent something better than a letter to
come and tell him about it
i hadn't heard that but i believe it
i've known some other people who used to
always
sit on everything they've got and they
said if it's really important they'll
call me
now i think that probably doesn't work
it's an extreme solution yeah yeah
exactly
um
thinking about
when you first arrived at your job the
last job that you had in the armed
forces you want to coordinate an awful
lot of different agencies what are some
of the lessons and stories that you got
from that i imagine that that was just a
catastrophe
it was hard
and i would say first my last job in
afghanistan there were 46 nations in the
coalition so you start with 46
nationalities all trying to align on a
military strategy for which i am the
commander
they're all good people they all want to
do well but they've got different
instructions from their home country
some of these countries that had a very
small force were getting daily calls
from the president
down to some
lieutenant colonel in afghanistan
getting from his head of state so you
know i'm trying to compete with that
then there's the cultural changes
because they all come with a different
perspective historically and culturally
so what i say to them is going to go
through a filter
both from me and theirs
then you've got different organizations
that aren't military
department of state intelligence
organizations united nations
nato all these different entities that
have different equities they have
different objectives
they they don't stand up and say they're
different but they're slightly enough
different
so that everything will be interpreted
through that lens or in some cases it
will be resisted based upon that and
then the last one is in many cases there
are big personalities who just
don't want to deal with another big
personality
and so
how do you get this tower of babel
to communicate and to align on something
the danger of course is superficially
it's easy you get a buddy in a room and
you say
do we want to solve climate change
and everybody goes
of course we do that that's a good thing
will everybody sign up to helping with
climate change absolutely okay
now we're going to do some specific
things
and then you've lost them they go oh
wait a minute not going to do that not
going to do this not going to you know
depending upon their equities and we
found out in the military
campaign as well
people
could philosophically agree and give you
the illusion
of unity
and then when you got to execution
you learned that it was going to be much
harder than that and it wasn't because
they were evil it was because everybody
comes to it with slightly different
equities and perspectives and
instructions in many cases this is
something that you talk about in your
new book about the the challenge of
moving from intention to action and how
important it is to actually find a a
place where the rubber meets the road
and to start to act on things what are
some of the principles that you relied
on to try and get that over the line
from armchair philosophy to
uh
on the ground action
yeah we're talking about overcoming
inertia and of course inertia says an
object at rest remains at rest or an
object in motion remains in motion in
the same direction and velocity unless
changed
so you got to first understand that it
is extraordinarily powerful
inertia is always the easiest option
people are very rarely criticized for
doing nothing or they can at least find
a way to dodge criticism for doing
nothing they'll say i didn't have enough
information on you know this this this
but if you do something you're sort of
hanging out there
and so what we found is you've got to be
very specific you have got to set
requirements sometimes deadlines
sometimes very specific actions that
must be taken
and of course you have to start by
getting people
committed to the idea that action was
going to happen you know not just a head
nod you've got to actually get people
believing
that something is going to happen
and and that can be hard the second
thing is you've got to do very concrete
things that says
we are going to do this in accordance
with this timeline and you are
responsible for this part of it you
personally are accountable
you know a friend of mine has a great
quote that i use all the time it says if
three people are tasked to feed the dog
the dog's gonna starve
and he's he's actually right because
on the surface you say well three people
hey the dog's gonna be good to go no
as soon as
somebody doesn't know that they are
ultimately responsible for something
happening they will rationalize that
well somebody else is going to do it
and so you've got to take that
uh ability away from them you got to
sweep away all the fact that they can
hide from accountability
diseconomies of scale in that way are
one of the main reasons why you see look
at small startups look at the these tiny
companies that have got less than 100
employees and are worth billions and
billions of dollars why it's because
they're agile because the diseconomies
of scale many of which come with
communication they haven't kicked in yet
you got like the bird and lime these
scooter companies that are just
annihilate there's a period when i was
in america
where every month that i was that i
think i was in your country for like two
months
month one to month two they 10x their
value and month two to month three they
10x their value so i'd left and these
companies were massive i couldn't
believe it i thought right okay what's
going on here and it's the fact that
they're so agile they're able to move
and change as they need the
communication's frictionless
and on top of that you have direct
accountability when your entire
marketing department is like
john and mary and this other guy over
there like there's three people that you
need to speak to and each of them has a
very very defined task okay john they're
looking after paid and marry you do
copywriting and whatever like that's it
so i think
one of the things that i found that's
very useful
uh time communication in with this when
i have a phone call especially a group
call with a bunch of my guys so let's
say that me and a couple of the other
directors are talking about our
nightlife business
and at the end of the call i'll always
summarize and say all right man so i'm
going to go away and i'm going to do
this and this and this and dave you need
to ring this person and we need to check
on the pricing for this and blah blah
and darren you've got this this and this
and it just especially with
non-written communication that lack of a
record
gives enough slippage for people to i
don't remember
i don't seem to recall stan you
mentioned i don't seem to remember you
saying that in the meeting and yeah
that's a nice way to do it i think
providing that summary keeping
everything as agile as possible uh yeah
those are two tactics that i've used
that i think work well
chris i think those are very good the
one i'd add to that is start the next
meeting with the list of things you said
we're going to get done
and and look to each person say did it
get done did it get done did get done
and after a couple times people will go
i can't walk away and let it hope that
everybody will forget it
what about structure that's something
that we're kind of talking about here
big companies or small companies what's
an optimal way to structure to mitigate
risk
i know it sounds terrible but it depends
the first thing about risk is our
structure is that we create these big
comfortable structures and as you said
unfortunately they can give us this
illusion of stability and so if you work
for a big massive company and you don't
do your job very well that massive
company is going to survive or at least
you believe it is
you can do something or not do something
and you know it's going to be okay
because you just don't have enough
responsibility to move the needle by
your negligence or whatever
so that's one thing but the problem with
structure or that's one problem
structure the other problem is it
creates pathways it creates expectations
that can be very tortured
you know you can have to go to your boss
in your boss's boss your boss's boss's
boss and your boss's boss's boss to get
approval for something and on paper that
makes sense because it gives people at
every level visibility and oversight and
wisdom and all this stuff but the
reality is it makes it so slow
or it's such a filtering process that a
certain time you just don't bother you
say i'm not going to do it and it's not
that you sit down where you are and
innovate and drive the company you tend
to say well you know there's just no
point in working that hard to do it
so structure can create a lack of
communication it can create a lack of
accountability although interestingly
structures were designed
to make accountability clear
so its structure itself is not evil
but structure that becomes overburdened
or not executed correctly is and then
understanding that when a structure
exists and it gets damaged
and the organization is structure based
then suddenly when that structure is
atomized the organization has a very
difficult time operating
well blitzkrieg for example the german
tactic in world war ii
and others have used it as well was not
to destroy the enemy forces it was to go
in disrupt the communications and once
you disrupted the community
communications your enemy is atomized
now they can't
coherently synchronize or coordinate
their activities
we sometimes atomize our own
organizations just by how we structure
them
how we do communications in them
you know
research and development doesn't talk to
marketing who doesn't talk to supply
chain people who doesn't talk you know
and so as a consequence we get the wrong
product to deliver to the wrong place
with the wrong requirement and so and
people all go well how did that happen
and that happened because we let our
structure
limit us we let our structure put us in
silos or put us in lanes that inhibited
communication is the most obvious part
but it inhibited the ability to get
things done
it seems like the obvious solution to
that is more meetings
you know it can feel like it you know
there's a time because one things
meetings do is they they put out
information another is they make leaders
feel comfortable how many times you've
been to a meeting where a leader gets a
briefing just so that they think okay
i'm sure everybody's rolling
we did that and for years we did it
every week so we run nightclubs and
every single week remembering that
everyone's been out drinking the night
before but me and my business partner
would have it at 11am which we figured
was
it was late enough that people would be
sober but not so late that the hangover
would have kicked in super badly that
was we'd kind of tried to find a
goldilocks zone and um and we'd sit down
and every single week we'd have the same
conversation right so and so you your
team hasn't performed very well and
yours has and blah blah blah and
everyone's on the same page and you're
right a big part of that was
it was like this public display
from us to the managers and to ourselves
look i am doing my job everyone is here
if they're suffering through that
hangover with everybody else at least at
least we've got this bit right even if
the nights didn't go well um so yeah
what's a what's a better solution
well i think the first is
meetings are not all evil and i'll
circle back to that
but we now have information technology
where we can get feeds and create
dashboards so many of the things that we
cover in meetings you can already have
you can be tracking those in real time
sales numbers so so-and-so etc so that
when you go into the meeting you're not
rehashing information you're not just
laying data out what you're doing is
you're saying okay what are we going to
do about the parts of this that are not
the way we want them to be
and i think that gets you very focused
now the other part though is understand
that the goodness of meetings if they're
done correctly is creating trust and
cohesion
you're starting to communicate with
people if everybody stays in their home
or in their cubicle and they just have
their data go and they don't build the
links that the trust requires
you know have and so sometimes having
meetings particularly with video
teleconference capability
just lets me see the other person and i
can say yeah i know chris he's he's
working hard i like him i empathize with
him
where if you're just at the top of an
email or something like that it doesn't
happen so
i would tell leaders be intentional
about what the purpose of the meeting is
and try to to bring as much value out of
it as you can
what about bias and diversity those are
two
elements i think that are quite uh that
in vogue at the moment as talking about
trying to get different voices into the
workplace
but it can seem like virtue signaling it
can seem like it's being done simply for
the sake of it and bias comes with a
pretty sort of loaded set of assumptions
as well so what's a what's a better way
to think about diversity and bias
yeah i'll swing around to bias in a
moment but diversity i think we think
incorrectly about it
you know we use in in our book we talk
about a lack of diversity and we take
the bay of pigs in 1961 brand new
administration under president john f
kennedy takes over he gets a bunch of
old white guys around
and they have this plan briefed to him
to invade cuba wasn't a very good plan
on any level wasn't a good idea and it
wasn't planned very well and it wasn't
executed very well but
what we point out is although many of
them were veterans from world war ii and
they now were civilians in government
it wasn't the problem that they were all
white guys that was the nature of
government in those days the problem was
that you didn't have diversity of
perspectives in the room you didn't have
people with different viewpoints and so
the term groupthink actually came out of
a study of the bay of pigs a guy named
janice came up with it when he studied
it and the the dynamics of groupthink
go forward 18 months and you have the
cuban missile crisis president kennedy
is a little bit more seasoned as a a
president now
he has this really big crisis potential
nuclear war and who's he assembled a
bunch of old white guys
and you go now wait a minute why did he
do that well again nature of 1962
government
but he did it differently because this
time the old white guys were not lacking
diversity he brought in people
intentionally with different viewpoints
and he set up a process which required
them to surface those differences he
teased out the differences to give him
more options to choose from because on
day one of the crisis they came in and
they said
bomb cuba invade you know etc and that
was like the course of action but he
teased it out so the point i make on
diversity is we we walk in a room and we
see
all men or all women are all something
we go it's not diverse
or we walk in a room and we see
different races different genders and we
say it is diverse that's not the right
measure the measure is different
perspectives different backgrounds
different expertise different
experiences
and so
if we think of diversity as a moral
imperative i said we're thinking wrong
equality of opportunity is a moral
imperative that's something we should do
and we should fight for
diversity is an operational imperative
we don't do it because it's right we do
because it's smart and because it works
and we've got to separate the two and
often
you know diversity will look like
diversity in our minds but sometimes it
won't it's really important that we
understand what we're doing here then
you circle around the bias one second on
that on that stand the
the problem that you have with diversity
is that
by having less diversity you have more
cohesive
communication more cohesion and
coherence within the group right that
there's less likelihood for friction
because everyone's coming out from the
same perspective there's no reason for
us to to
disagree with each other so how can you
balance the desire for diversity with
the requirement for a cohesive
communication structure
yeah that's a great one
i think there are a couple things the
first is you've got to have diversity or
you're never going to get that voice
that reminds you that what the group
thinks may not be right
so even though it's painful you've got
to bring the outside voices into the
room i was put on a couple boards of
directors i was one at deutsche bank usa
because i was a non-banker
because i didn't understand banking but
i would ask stupid questions that
occasionally were helpful
you know i'd like this sounds stupid
and a banker would look at me and go
yeah you know actually it is stupid yeah
okay
so
so that is one of the key things now you
do have to have a dynamic that says
i
i think of it in phases there's a phase
in which you get everybody's information
and opinions then a decision is made and
there's an execution phase
now unless something changes when you go
into the execution phase all the
naysayers should essentially shut up
they should get on board because unless
the organization unites to execute
you'll never be effective
it's not effective to just always be the
person in the back of the room saying
well you know i'm i didn't think this
was a good idea we shouldn't do it you
got to get on board and
you know it's it's a careful line if
something criminal or whatever you
shouldn't get on board but if it's a
basic decision you have your say you
have the argument and then then you move
forward with that but too often leaders
want to surround themselves with a greek
chorus of people who will
say you know you are
a handsome man you're a powerful man
your decisions are great and that's
that's not in the end helpful what was
that like in the army because
for me
on the outside looking in it's quite
rigid you think about hierarchy you
think about structure and
not a dictatorship but there's people
that have degrees of superiority and
they're supposed to speak down what's
the feedback loop like in the armed
forces
yeah it's interesting it varies by unit
but the reality is you have to work
really hard to get candid communication
up because everyone wears their position
on their uniform not only are you
do they know you're the boss it says it
on your uniform with your rank and
whatnot and so there's this seniority
there's this experience and there's this
rank and junior people are very reticent
to step up and say something is stupid
so there are a couple of techniques you
use one is in what they call a council
of war but in any meeting
you've got something you're proposing
an experienced commander when they ask
people are opinions they'll start with
the most junior person
and they'll go in reverse order so that
that person each person isn't tainted by
more senior people
the second is the art of asking
questions
if i go out and i ask junior people
and i'm the general and i say how's my
strategy working
you know they're gonna say sir it's
brilliant you know what else are they
gonna say they know it's my strategy and
they know that i'd like to hear it's
working
instead you have to ask leading
questions that say okay
what would you do differently i used to
ask a question sort of famously i'd say
if i told you you can't leave
afghanistan until we win
what would you do differently
and it worked very well because they
kind of laugh wondering if i could
actually keep them there forever
and but then they would get very
thoughtful in their responses and they
go hey sir you know i know what we're
saying but down here i'll tell you
here's what you have to do if you want
to solve the problem
and then you start to get
more
honest feedback but but it's hard it's
still hard you have to create the
environment you have to listen
if you ask a junior person or opinion
you have to laser focus on them because
as soon as you look over your shoulder
and act like you're thinking about
something else you've signaled you
didn't really want their opinion
and so
every organization has this challenge in
the military it's just very overt yeah i
read uh i can't remember the author's
name but it was a biography of john boyd
the fighter pilot and
he didn't care much for seniority it
sounded like based on what i read there
but what did come through was the
challenges of this rigid structure the
fact that you do have
some
people some senior people within any
organization who aren't used to that who
aren't used to having somebody that
pushes back against their ideas and
one of the things that keeps coming up
that we haven't spoken about creativity
is the fact that if you have poor
communication that limits your
creativity if you have insufficient
diversity and if the structure's wrong
as well if you have too many checks and
balances all the way up and all the way
down creativity gets limited because
someone can't be bothered because they
know it's got to be certified 55 times
or whatever it might be and um
yeah i think
that's that feels like one of the most
difficult challenges that leaders have
at the moment is to balance between
allowing people to communicate freely
and openly within a group and allowing
everyone to know what's going on not
losing everybody in this overwhelm of
information creating enough structure to
keep people moving and keep that
momentum going but not having so much
structure that it's con confines people
in and restrictive and stops creativity
like it's no surprise that leadership
and the work that you do and coaching
companies and stuff like that it's no
surprise that it's needed because it's
really really hard
yeah amazingly so and one of the points
you were making is
iconoclasts or rebels who often have
something really good to say often also
have really abrasive personalities so
it's one thing to tell the people above
we should do it differently it's another
thing to start it with your fools you
know
you shouldn't have your jobs
you're gonna cut off reception
and billy mitchell and other leaders in
in history have run into that problem
and so while they may have been pushing
something that was very right sometimes
the messenger becomes as much of a
problem as the receptor
and so it's a it's a pretty interesting
dynamic it's creating an organization
though that welcomes that and i'd go
back to your creativity point i think
it's key one of the things i learned in
special operations with very mature
people is don't give them tasks
if you give them a task that's fairly
narrow
you say okay i want you to go here do x
they will do that
step back and give them broad missions
and say this is the problem
and this is
this the kind of solution we want to get
to now the task may end up being very
obvious and they may have to do it that
way but in other cases they will step
back and they'll say okay what are we
really trying to do you've opened the
door you've almost challenged them to be
creative
and and every once in a while i would
get with the really good ones and i'd
have a difficult problem and i'd say i
don't think this is solvable
i don't think there's a way to to do
that but will you guys look at it and of
course they immediately puff themselves
up and they go i've just challenged
their manhood
and and so they come and they come back
with some amazing stuff i remember
seeing something
that you put about
the difference between dictating
a task for someone to complete and
allowing them to be the creator of the
solution to it and the difference in
terms of buy-in that you get with that
is yeah it's worlds apart
it's complete i mean
you know if you tell them what to do and
it goes poorly they'll just say hey boss
made a bad decision
but if you say i want you to solve the
problem figure out what it is and tell
me what you did don't come for
permission just do it
they own it then and you see this
completely different level of commitment
what about bias well bias is interesting
because we think of bias as evil we
think if someone's a racist or they
whatever bias they've got
bias is logical
meaning it comes from your
position i describe in the book that
uh
southerners in the pre-civil war united
states even for a
century after that
everybody says they were racist and the
answer is were they racist
yeah
but they were racist for a reason
because their economy was built on free
or slave labor
you couldn't have slaves unless you
bought into the idea that they were
inferior
so it was in your interest to have
slaves economically therefore it was in
your interest to convince yourself that
they are inferior and worthy of being
slaves
and so i'm convinced they could pass a
lie detector test
that they believed all that because of
course they would if we look at other
perspectives now
instead of people just being evil look
at why they believe something look at
the reason behind it and
getting people to change their biases is
not always impossible but it's
extraordinarily hard
in my experience you're more
likely just going to have to understand
those biases and factor them in to
include your own
yeah it's an interesting one to think
about
the vast majority of people with whom
you disagree
are convinced of their position
yes most people aren't disagreeing with
you with the information that you have
in your head and then willfully deciding
to get rid of that and then just take
some opposite point of view no they're
convinced of course they are if you had
what they had in their heads you would
be convinced of it as well
exactly
you know i've told people many times we
were fighting against al qaeda or the
taliban
had i had their life journey
i'd think exactly what they'd think and
i'd be on their side of the table
so again they're not irrational it's
just from a different perspective this
is why we need to be incredibly careful
about judging the actions of people
especially from the past there's a lot
of retrospective shaming that we're
doing at the moment on social media and
you need to think man like
can you judge the actions of yesterday
by the standards of today
no no anybody anybody that spends even a
minute thinking about that realizes that
that's
not an effective route to go down does
that mean you should still propagate
those ideas today no absolutely not
there are some things that need to you
know they need to be lost to the winds
of time but they were there and you
can't call people evil like throwing
terms around like evil people john
peterson talks about this he says people
presume that if they lived in world war
ii germany that they wouldn't have been
one of the nazis it's like no of course
you would like you would have had to
have been an unbelievably unique human
for that to have not been the case
that's exactly right and one of the
beauties though is the people in the
past who are dead can't fight back
so we can rip their names off buildings
knock down their statues criticize them
all day long because they're not here to
defend themselves
what about adaptability
if we don't adapt we lose and yet and we
all think we're adaptable we you know we
all say well i adapt to whatever but the
reality is adaptation requires a couple
of things
it requires some reason to adapt some
either what you have is it working and
then the ability to adapt you gotta have
enough maneuver space to adapt in the
book we talk about dick fosberry who
changed the way people did high jumping
and he did that after trying every other
technique for years to be a high jumper
not being competitive
but he came up with the idea you could
throw yourself over backwards but he
could only do that because they changed
the landing areas they used to just use
sand you you did the high jump literally
land on a little bit of sand if you
landed back on your your neck you'd
break your neck so they didn't
by the time he in in 1968 they had these
big thick crash pads
so it's actually a different sport it's
a different challenge because he can do
things that would have been suicidal 10
years before
and so you've got to understand when
the requirement to adapt is there and
the ability to adapt
enough freedom
of action to adapt and then of course we
got to be mentally willing to adapt
because it gets back to inertia
many times we won't adapt just because
we're used to what we're doing
or because we're scared to adapt or we
haven't thought about it there's any
number of reasons we don't adapt
naturally
i like we think we do but i think we
only adapt when
you know it's kind of forced upon us
can you tell the story of how you left
the army because that seems to me to be
a story of adaptability
yeah i i was in the army for 34 years i
graduated from west point then a little
bit over 34 years
and
in my uh near the end of my
first year in afghanistan as the
commander of isaf
there was a reporter who came and did a
story on our team and he produced this
story in rolling stone magazine and i
thought the story was inaccurate
you know i thought it was a depiction
that was not a fair depiction but it
didn't matter because when it came out
it came out at a politically charged
period and it put the president a very
difficult position and so
you know generals aren't supposed to put
their commander-in-chief in a difficult
position so i offered my resignation to
president obama with no ill feelings i
said you know
that this story happened i didn't i
didn't think it was fair but it doesn't
matter
and he he accepted my resignation
well clearly in a second
i went from being a soldier
my whole life from age 17 on to not
being a soldier and in the short term of
course i'm on the news disgrace general
all the things that go with it so you've
got the the challenge of dealing with
that but longer term you have the
challenge of being something different
and you have to decide how you're going
to live you've got to decide who you are
because i'd spend a lifetime
self-identifying as a soldier
and now
i can't and shouldn't do that
and so i made a decision then and it
wasn't a conscious decision where i went
out in the desert and sat for 40 days
i
my wife helped me with it we didn't
really talk about it very much
but very quickly we made the decision
that we weren't going to try to
relitigate the past we weren't going to
argue what happened in the past we
weren't going to be bitter because you
could spend a lifetime
being a bitter former general
and a lot of people would have you out
to lunch for that but but what what's
the point so i decided at that point
that i was going to live my life going
forward i was going to be something
different
i started a business i started teaching
i started writing
and but i made the decision that those
things about me that were very important
to me and those were the values that i
thought i represented and that i held
and the
relationship i had with a number of
people whose
affection i and respect i cared deeply
about that i was going to conduct myself
in a way that they would not feel
like
i wasn't the person that they had
believed in
that they were going to decide no stan
is what he said he was and is what he
acted like
that the article's an aberration and he
still is and so sort of every day i've
tried to be that going forward
and you ask well
does it ever hurt do you ever get angry
at you know and the answer is does it
hurt her
um
do i get angry no because what's the
point
you know there's nothing to be there's
no body or anything to be angry at
all you can do is pick up and say how
can i make my life and my contribution
as good as it can be
and that's worked really well
because i've i've ended up with a great
place in life i've ended up with an
amazing set of friends opportunities i
never would have had otherwise
and so out of everything that i would
not have chosen to have happen
i've got an extraordinary number of of
wonderful outcomes
it's interesting that the fundamental
you came back to there is values
it's something grounding that even in
the turmoil of public
disgrace or humiliation or just a
disadvantageous situation
it's interesting that that's the thing
that you come back to and i
i don't know i think that what we're
seeing at the moment is the upending of
a lot of people's values you know
tradition is baby bath water and bath
all being thrown out of the window
and it doesn't give people a very firm
place to stand and then when you do come
up against something that requires a bit
more resilience what are you holding on
to
yeah there's a great article the world
of epectitis and it was admiral
stockdale who won the medal of honor
from being a
prisoner of war in hanoi for seven years
during the vietnam war and what he comes
back to is he didn't control his
physical surroundings he was tortured he
was broken
but he held on to his values he had a
set of values based in philosophy and
religion and just his personal being
and no matter what else happened
those were what
he was able to cling to and i would say
that that's what i think what i as you
mentioned now i think there are a lot of
people who are mortgaging their values
for short-term gain
and they're going to hit a point in
their life when they look in the mirror
or their grandchildren look at them and
they'll kind of go
grandmama or granddaddy why did you do
that
and it's going to be a very painful time
and i almost wish that if they got the
chance to step back and think about it
they could make another calculation if
you sell your integrity you can't buy it
back
and when it comes to
even a more a less esoteric and a more
trendy equivalent of it you can't out
hustle being uncool so we see this with
content creators online that someone
will do a thing they'll find that their
their message resonates with a
particular audience and they'll lean
into it and lean into it and lean into
it and they'll increase their blind
spots and their biases to the point
where you go
dude you're just a you're just a puppet
for that particular audience you're not
even a person anymore you're just this
caricature of yourself giving these
people this gray sludge that is exactly
what they expected and i had a comedian
on the show ryan long and he said man
the only thing that i want when i look
back on my career is to have a
body of work that i think is cool that i
look back on i think that's cool i'm
proud of that i'll show that to people
and not be embarrassed about it it's
like if you start with that end in mind
it's a pretty good place to go
but i wonder how many people
that we're seeing operate at the moment
could look back on the things that
they're putting out into the world and
say yeah i'm really glad that i tweeted
that had that meeting spent that time
with that family member had that
discussion treated my partner in that
way i don't think that i don't think
that a lot of people would say they did
yeah i think you've nailed it and
it's one of the things going back to
when i said we can
communicate faster than we can think and
also the power of applause or positive
reaction to something you say something
ridiculous or outrageous and people
cheer
and that's
hypnotic and you start to or
you know you want more of that but it's
really dangerous there's a term for it
in the creator community it's called
audience capture
and audience capture is a hell of a drug
man all right so we've spoken about some
of the challenges around risk what about
some of the solutions must be a tactic
or two that people can implement so that
they can actually get out ahead of these
vulnerabilities
yeah absolutely the first is understand
that you have responsibility for it you
your organization it's not something
that is done to you you do it think in
terms of the human immune system we've
got this miracle system that detects
threats to us assesses them as dangerous
or not responds to them and then learns
we've got the equivalent in our
organizations a risk immune system it's
the number of factors like communication
narrative bias diversity timing
if we strengthen those
then we are ready for those threats no
matter what they are there are a number
of things you can do we talked about
some of the techniques to get
uh more open communication there's one
i'd throw out it's red teaming
and that is you've got a plan or a
strategy to do something to your company
organization and you fall in love with
it because it's yours and you've worked
on it a long time so necessarily you
become a bit blind
if you bring in a small team they can be
part of your organization but they
should be a step away from the plan
itself
and task them
to muck it up
say what could you do as a competitor or
as customers or as problem creators what
could you do
to do it and what they're really doing
is pressure testing your plan they'll
find the gaps and seams and weaknesses
and it's really upsetting because you
will have created this wonderful
thing and they will come and clever
little people will crush it and it'll
make you look stupid and if you're
human like too many people are you will
say no i
you know i reject that
then you lose if you're smart you look
and say let me find all these holes
patch them up make it better and iterate
again
it's that willingness
to give people the opportunity to find
your blind spots
and that's a short-term mental idea and
it's actually a a formal construct
organizations can do with great
uh success what's a gap analysis
a gap analysis is the difference between
what you're doing and what you should be
doing and it sounds
self-evident but
in many cases you
you're doing a bunch of things in your
organization and then you look at what
actually has to be done
or what need and you'll find a gap
and sometimes people won't have raised
it up and and it will find the ability
to say okay we've got to address that
gap we gotta put more people here more
effort change the plan etc yeah it's an
interesting one the the wargaming thing
is that similar to red team
no war gaming is
it it can help do the same war gaming is
a more formal process where you lay out
your plan and then you go through the
execution of your strategy in step by
step
and the military will do a big war game
where you go through the unfolding of a
plan and you'll have an opponent do you
still have little
little models that you push around with
like a broom handle or is it more
sophisticated than that now it's it's
more computerized now but when i was a
junior officer we still had those and we
would push tanks around
yeah
but what it does is it puts your plan
through when your plan starts to get
under pressure and fall apart you have
to keep fighting it
and so as you keep fighting it you learn
where the weaknesses are and you also
just get practice in doing it yeah
really powerful
general stanley mcchrystal ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much for coming
on today if people want to check out
more of your stuff where should they go
the crystalgroup.com so just one word
mccrystalgroup.com
they can get to speeches they can get to
books they can get to anything that
might interest them thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that then
press here for a selection of the best
clips from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace